So the idea of Potential-based Shaping
is going to be this.
Instead of giving little bonuses for
good things happening,
what we're actually going to do is
put bonuses on states of the world.
Then when you achieve a certain state
of the world you get that bonus.
And if you unachieve that state
of the world you lose that bonus.
So everything kind of
balances out nicely.
So we'll write down an equation for
that in a moment but
let's see if we can think about what
state based rewards might look like
in the context of this little soccer
example we were talking about.
>> Okay.
>> So the official reward function has
us getting a +100 for scoring a goal but
we wanted to give hints.
We wanted to give hints
to the system for
getting near the ball, hitting the ball,
getting the ball near the goal.
So we need to do that,
we need to define that now in
terms of the states of the world.
So what would be some appropriate
rewards that we could put in for that?
>> Well, I mean, I think they would be
very similar to the ones that we were
talking about before, right?
If you're talking about states, you want
to be in the state of the ball moving
towards the goal, or
the ball being near the goal,
or you moving towards the ball,
or kicking the ball.
Those are all states you
would like to be in, right?
>> Yeah, okay.
All right, so yeah, and the way
that we were writing that before,
I think, was something like 1 over
the distance between us and the ball.
And 1 over the distance
between the ball and the goal.
But now we think of these as being
bonuses that are tied to the state.
Not values that we're getting for
becoming close to the ball.
So there's always this value,
this potential that's keeping track
of how close we are to the ball.
And when we're close to the ball,
it's a big number.
And when we're far from
the ball it's a small number.
And the reward that we're going to get,
is we change from state to state,
how much more potential
have we've gotten?